and I think what matters to the
customers at the end of the day is
obviously what they can do with it they
don't really care about uh this
wavelength that much microns or or
whatnot but what what it translates to
uh and again with us it translates to
lower costs and also higher quality and
that's actually what uh yes that's what
makes us uh that's what makes us
different and that's what allows us to
actually go to the Holy Grail of the
whole industry
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
talking about 3D printing with Ido Elon
a well-rounded experienced business
executive with International mindset
idolon is 3dm's CEO and board member Ido
has a vast experience in the additive
manufacturing industry in various roles
and positions he started his journey in
the industry with strategists where he
assumed positions in Israel North
America and Asia Pacific being close to
the marketing customers he gained a lot
of experience and insights on the
industry's landscape in his last role
before joining 3dm he though held the
position of Vice President sales and
marketing in Mercedes leading the
company's go to market organization
worldwide it though holds a BSC in
biomedical engineering from Ben-Gurion
University
I'm really excited to have you here you
know talking about manufacturing
printing your own Journey what's been
happening in the space over the last
several years today you're the CEO of
3dm digital manufacturing and so I'm
looking forward to uncovering a little
bit about this company as well and how
you're sitting into a sort of this whole
new industry that's emerging and the way
that this is shaping our world and so
without further Ado even though tell me
a little bit about yourself your your
journey what got you into Manufacturing
in the first place
okay so uh amido as you said
um uh um I'm actually very uh I'm
actually I'm actually part of the 3D
printing industry for the last 15 years
or so uh my I started as a uh as an
applications uh and uh pre-sales if you
want uh team leader
um and that is actually uh that is
actually where it started and that is
actually sits in the in the junction of
where uh uh you know technology uh meets
uh technology and product meets uh uh
customers and and use cases so that
actually got me very excited early on
and again 15 years ago it wasn't as
known as it is today although I must
admit that the Technologies are actually
much older than that but back then we
had to explain what 3D printing is and
there were very exciting days you know I
I could start a day talking to a doctor
then later on talk to a shoe
manufacturer and then from there to an
automotive
manufacturer and then at late night talk
to maybe a university so it really
it was really and still is by the way a
very disruptive technology for all type
of Industries so it is very very diverse
and very very interesting uh both of
them and now
I I know 3D printing through you know
growing up and going to different you
know hacker maker stations and having 3D
printers there and on Kickstarter I
remember some of the first 3D printers
that became a you know widely available
for consumers
what share with me a little bit about
sort of the progress of 3D printing and
that what what changes represents in
from a manufacturer's perspective and
I'd love to understand both the the
consumer use cases like the ones that I
perhaps have experienced in the
Makerspace as well as those of the the
Enterprise use cases or the more Global
B2B use cases
yeah so it actually started it all
started I think as a very high-tech uh
uh you know technology uh it was aimed
for Enterprises and and really
industrial use uh and mostly around the
prototyping and uh and maybe model
making then I think uh a few years later
maybe a little bit more than a few years
later the technology actually uh got
better as usually uh as usually happen
with other Technologies as well it got
better and a lot of people and a lot of
users actually Enterprises uh wanted to
uh try and so I think there is a split
at that point right so the Enterprises
wanted to use the more of the prototypes
uh so in terms of like being able to
prototype more than the uh than they
prototype before but also use it for
more than just prototyping so that was
one uh type of uh maybe a direction the
other direction was actually to get the
um the a technology to make it more
available and there was a uh there were
a lot of slogans you know like
democratization of design and freedom of
design Etc and that was actually
bringing the technology to uh uh to more
uh kind of the the masses and that was
where maybe you uh uh the hackathons and
the maker faires that we mentioned were
around that mostly these both happened
uh kind of like uh at the same time
roughly
um and uh and I think still today uh
these are maybe uh the two main streams
and each one goes more and more uh in
its own collect Direction uh I think
back then you know when we just started
uh or when when the uh when the consumer
kind of like uh Direction just started
uh it was uh there was maybe a dream
that everyone would be able to print
whatever they want at their own houses I
mean if you uh kind of like you know if
you break cure glass then maybe you can
print one Etc I don't think that that
really happened and to be honest I don't
think that it will happen at some point
in time what I do think that will happen
is is that the technology will be more
accessible through uh different more and
more uh different uh centralized service
providers to help uh get the consumers
uh what they need uh roughly at uh I'd
say at the reasonable time if you want
but at much higher quality than they
could do themselves right kind of like
what happened we're also in 2D printing
I mean I don't know I don't know if you
own a 2d printer or not but usually if
you need a printout of any document or
something like that you usually go to
like a center that can do that they
probably have a better uh printer than
you would purchase your own and and they
can actually uh get you what uh what you
need the relatively at a higher quality
than you would do your self and also at
a very reasonable time and and what not
in cost
so interesting yeah
the um the the hypothesis that on the
consumer side it's not necessarily going
to be a key player for households is
that is that um something that you know
there is an agreement on are you a
contrarian with that view where where do
you stand on the sort of those scale of
manufacturing thought leaders that are
thinking about the future of of this
space
so to be honest I don't know exactly uh
the answer to your uh question I do know
that uh some people would probably
disagree with what I said I do think
that uh the uh the reason that I say it
is mostly around the ability to create
the content that uh that is uh then
needs to be printed so I think uh any
kid these days that has a smartphone or
even before then can create a document
or a photograph for example to be
printed but it's a little bit still more
complicated to create things to be 3D
printed
so that is uh maybe one I think uh one
of the most significant let's say
um uh you know drawbacks or or maybe uh
uh barriers uh for that to happen the
way that people imagined back then but
still interesting the technology will
will change almost everybody's life I
mean uh for sure it's already been a few
years that uh you probably uh you and I
both touched uh you know uh products
these days just today that you know that
that 3D printing played a key uh role in
their uh either design manufacturing or
uh or development stages so uh
definitely it has a lot of impact in the
world but not necessarily the way that
it was imagined back then uh
specifically on the consumer level on
the uh Enterprise level actually I do
think that
the direction and this is where 3dm will
will maybe go into the uh into play
on the Enterprises level I do think that
the the main thought was how to move
from prototyping to manufacturing and
how the technology can actually benefit
not only prototyping and development
Cycles but but also actual end use
Products
Manufacturing
and that is uh you know that is uh
something that uh I think the the
leaders of the industry actually are
very much uh very much engaged with and
very much uh uh trying to
try to
to tackle in order to make the
technology much more uh beneficial for
production it is already it is already
in production for many many Industries
but the scale is probably not as high as
people would want to and also there are
more Industries to uh to disrupt with
this uh with this technology so I don't
know I don't know fantastic that covered
what you want what you asked for but
that's uh kind of like tell me you know
let's talk about 3dm so what what what's
the call what's this comp company that
you're currently the Chief Executive
Officer of what is sort of its role and
its Vision yeah great so 3dm actually is
a is a a 3D printing technology uh
company and uh we uh we'll look at
manufacturing so that's that's our main
interest we're not so much into the
consumer uh products uh but we are
creating uh uh the uh Cutting Edge
Technologies for production with 3D
printing we're all about Plastics by the
way we did not cover that during my
previous uh answer to your question but
uh the industry has many many different
materials Plastics is probably the
biggest in terms of volume and we're all
in Plastics we make uh technology for
Selective laser sintering uh in Plastics
as mentioned
and it is all about production and it's
all about
manufacturing
the main barriers the men two barriers
for SLS manufacturing these days in
order in order for for the technology to
go further into manufacturing for a much
higher greater scale of manufacturing
is there there are two main barriers one
of them is the quality of the printing
which actually also kind of like splits
into uh the uh resolution and uh surface
quality Etc and the other one is also
the uh the strength if you want or the
isotropy of the uh of the parts being
strong in all different directions and
that is probably maybe the two main
differences between what people or
consumers would be used to as as and use
product and the 3D printed
output and we actually in 3dm deal with
these two these two barriers we create
things that are uh at higher quality and
also at a much lower cost so the
barriers the cost and the quality these
are two barriers that we deal with
um we create technology that is based on
our own or on our own laser so I'll just
say that SLS technology The Selective
Laser sintering Technology is a
technology that is is out there for a
few decades now we did not invent that
technology but within that category
which is already at the Forefront of uh
manufacturing with 3D printing we
actually create our own let's say
subcategory we're the only ones that
make their own lasers all SLS
manufacturers use of the Shelf lasers
and they're very limited in terms of the
wavelength that they use we make our own
lasers we control the wavelengths and
that is actually
very important for us to uh be able to
aim uh the for for uh the right let's
say light and material
light and material uh kind of uh
correspondence and that's how we can
actually make our own uh again make our
own lasers with our own uh dedicator or
or kind of like programmed or uh
designed wavelengths so we can actually
make the sintering process much much uh
much much better that results in getting
higher quality and lower cost and we can
do everything much much faster which
again these are all the things that
actually push the technology further
into production and Manufacturing
so are those really the elements of a
competitive advantage in your space what
we just mentioned is it are these sort
of the Holy Grail of what it would mean
to become a winner and the space to win
the larger contracts to get you know
better you know I guess credibility or
trust because I'm guessing that in this
in this space you know you're you're you
know there's the people that are the
people that are ordering and there's the
people that are manufacturing and then
I'm curious as to what it takes to
really stand out in a space like this
I'm coming from software so so I'm sure
that it's a little bit different in the
sense
um but how do you stand out in in a
market where you know there's a there's
a bunch of different offerings and even
if you have the great a different
technology how do you make it no
yeah so it's uh well first of all it's
it's a battle and uh and we and we fight
this battle obviously uh but yes we are
very much different than any other any
other manufacturer out there at this
point in time uh we have our own lasers
as I mentioned and we're very unique
with the uh with these wavelength uh
um
and I think what matters to uh the
customers at the end of the day is
obviously what they can do with it they
don't really care about uh this
wavelength that much microns or uh or or
whatnot but what what it translates to
and again with us it translates to lower
costs and also higher quality and that's
actually what uh yes that's what makes
us uh that's what makes us different and
that's what allows us to actually go to
the Holy Grail of the whole industry
which again as I mentioned maybe there
are two holy Grails one of them is the
consumer level which we kind of like
covered before with uh uh uh and and the
the other one is the production level or
the manufacturing the mass manufacturing
level which is what we deal with uh and
yes and for that then I think the
technological advantage that we have is
is probably the uh the one thing that
makes us unique and the one that makes
us very different than others of course
course on top of that there are a lot of
other things that still needs to you
know needs to be put in place like uh
you know like distribution and customer
satisfaction uh things of that sort but
at this point in time or this uh stage
of the company we're very much focused
on uh uh getting the technology
uh out there
and that is our main Competitive Edge at
this point
and so where is 3dm in the space today
we're in the snapshot of time what was
what's happening in 3dm
okay so we we uh
um again as our core uh competency or
the capability that we have is uh is in
our own uh lasers as mentioned before we
are already engaged with some uh players
in the uh uh 3D printing uh industry uh
we have a few Pilots agreements uh with
SLS manufacturers to uh uh basically uh
try our technology on their systems and
uh to be able to go to market with these
uh combined uh um uh combined machines
and get them to Market much faster uh
that's uh one uh one pass that we go the
other path that we go is to create uh
very uh I would say
um uh Market or application dedicated uh
solution uh we'll probably not go with
go there our own we uh we plan on on
partnering with uh with key players
within these industries and just to be
able to tailor the best solution as
quick as possible around our technology
to make the production better and faster
and cheaper for that specific
application on that front by the way
we're very much different and again if
you think about the evolution of 3D
printing and how it happened then it was
you know it was uh mainly around let's
say a technology each company had its
own kind of like technology and call it
push that
forward
with basically trying to you know make a
a general purpose machine that can
actually cover as many uh as many
applications as possible we're actually
very much different in that uh in that
thinking we uh we want to create the
best solution tailored solution for
specific application and if it needs to
be product a it is comic released from
trying to be a able to do product B so
it it will have it will be it will be
very much uh dedicated and with
capabilities that are very much tailored
to a certain uh application in a certain
type of manufacturing and again this is
also probably uh probably a result of of
the uh the vision of uh again going into
manufacturing because you know a machine
that needs to do something does not
necessarily need to be able to do the
other thing as well
Mike 100 where do you find most the most
joy in satisfaction for what you do
where's that stemming from for you
well so uh you know as the leader of the
company I think uh uh bringing uh people
together
around or behind the certain uh certain
uh
um uh goal and vision is uh something
that I really enjoy doing uh and I think
you know uh getting things kind of like
planned and then executed uh uh
um uh is is probably the uh the most
satisfying so again I think I think it's
the ability to get a teamwork around or
behind a certain goal and then achieving
that goal with good planning and uh and
Brilliant execution
I love it you don't I really want to
thank you for your time and your your
energy and your effort and uh it sounds
like um
three game is a very special company in
the space and we got to learn a lot
about 3D printing and the space myself
over these 20 minutes and so just to
only raises the Curiosity around this so
again thank you thank you for being here
and for taking this time to share with
me and best of luck with the continued
battle and the continued Journey it
sounds like you're definitely enjoying
it so I hope you continue enjoying it
and thank you very very much thank you
very much Michael thanks
thank you